with Summer right around the corner I
can't wait to do some grilling so here's
how to make a shoestring fry burger with
the help of Grill mates we'll start by
cutting the potatoes into matchsticks
then fry until golden and super crispy
season with salt and pepper for the
burger sauce mix Mayo ketchup chopped
pickles mustard and some pickle brine
mix well and set aside now season the
patties with Grill mates Montreal steak
seasoning you can literally use this on
anything but I love using it on Burgers
now Grill the patties and red onions for
a few minutes on each side make sure not
to burn them not to assemble your
Masterpiece first spread the burger
sauce onto the bun then add the Patty
then the cheese grilled red onions
pickles lettuce and a handful of
shoestring fries
now we have the perfect burger for your
summer cookout